bien mes chers collègues nous
auditionnons maintenant monsieur jean
claude trichet gouverneur honoraire de
la banque de france
je me suis touché je vais vous
astreindre au sermon qui est habituel
devant une commission denquête alors
monsieur jean claude trichet prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité
voulez-vous levé la main droite et dire
je le jure je le jure merci beaucoup je
vous propose connaissant parfaitement
quel est l'objectif de notre commission
que vous preniez premièrement la parole
pendant environ dix minutes un quart
d'heure si vous le souhaitez pour nous
donner vos premières observations aux
premiers enseignements sur le sujet qui
nous intéresse
après quoi je passerai la parole à notre
rapporteur éric bocquet et
éventuellement à mes collègues ici
présents pour
enrichir et poursuivre le débat monsieur
chez vous avez la parole merci de
m'avoir conviés à vous rejoindre
j'ai vu dans les questions qui étaient
listés comme étant des questions de
d'intérêt pour le pour votre commission
qu'il y avait pas mal de questions
tournant autour d'eux des causes de la
crise financière internationale mondiale
que nous avons connue et que nous
continuons à vrai dire à vivre en ce
moment et donc j'ai pensé que dans
l'introduction que vous m'aviez que vous
aviez souhaité en dix minutes
peut-être était-il utile que je vous
donne le disons les leçons provisoire
d'ailleurs que je tire moi même de ces
événements que j'ai eu le privilège un
peu triste de vivre aux premières loges
si je puis dire avec quelques banquiers
centraux internationaux comme le brisant
la fed et les autres banques centrales
des grands pays avancés puisqu'il s'agit
d'une bien d'une crise des pays avancés
une crise des pays industrialisés et ce
n'est qu'il y a un an et demi à peu près
que j'ai quitté cette cette fonction qui
me conduisait donc à vivre ce qui aura
été historiquement la crise la plus
grave des pays avancés depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale et qui dans mon
nom ma propre analyse aurait pu être la
crise la plus grave depuis la première
guerre mondiale
si un certain nombre de dispositifs très
audacieux et est aussi bien de la part
des banques centrales que de la part des
gouvernements n'avaient pas été pris
pour arrêter le
effondrement du système que nous avons
que nous avions progressivement créé ton
voyez je ne suis pas de ce point de vue
là très calme je crois que nous avons
réellement vécu des événements et nous
vivons des événements d'une invitée
absolument exceptionnelle alors les
causes de ce que nous avons vécu sont
certainement multiples je note
évidemment une dimension de dérégulation
financière généralisée qui est né aux
états unis mais qui s'est ensuite étendu
à l'ensemble de l'économie mondiale et
qui est clairement reposait sur l'idée
que les marchés étaient d'une manière
générale les opérateurs l'ensemble des
institutions et des agents économiques
étaient capables d'identifier l'optimum
ceci correspond à la théorie dite des
marchés efficients qui avait été très
renforcée au moment paradoxalement peut
être de la crise des dot com
lorsque les la bulle financière et
d'autres comme a explosé le fait est
qu'en dépit d'un impact absolument
considérable sur un certain nombre dans
un ensemble de domaines par exemple les
indices du nasdaq ont été divisées par
trois mais il n'y a eu aucune
conséquence grave de nature systémique
pour l'ensemble du système financier
et pas non plus pour l'économie réelle
donc cette crise avaient été digérés de
manière tout à fait aisé et elle avait
renforcé certainement dans l'esprit des
analyses dans l'esprit des économistes
beaucoup d'économistes de la communauté
internationale tout entière
le sentiment que le système qui s'était
progressivement bâti était beaucoup plus
solide
beaucoup plus résilient comme on dit
aujourd'hui qu'on ne pouvait le penser
une autre dimension de la crise
financière a été celle de la pro
cyclique qualité comme on dit dans le
jargon c'est à dire de l'amplification à
la fois des bulles et de l'effondrement
de l'éclatement des bulles par un
certain nombre d'éléments dans le
fonctionnement de la système financier
international notamment les agences de
rating qui ont joué un rôle procyclique
entre guillemets important des règles
comptables qui ont également joué ce
rôle
les agences de rating les règles
comptables et 1 100 dans d'autres
éléments en amplifiant ce que nous
savions bien bien être aussi au coeur de
cette de ces grandes oscillations des de
l'économie réelle et l'économie
financière qui sont la spéculation les
esprits animaux comme dickens et je
crois aussi un certain nombre de
propriétés émergentes du monde
d'aujourd'hui qui sont liées aux
transformations extraordinaires que nous
avons connue sous l'angle financier du
fait des progrès de la technologie qui a
permis de transmettre l'information en
temps réel sans coup de faire des
calculs extrêmement complexe à coup
extrêmement faible et qui ont donc
permis aux grands marchés financiers aux
grandes structures financières de vivre
en symbiose avec des machines nous
vivons tous d'ailleurs en symbiose avec
des machines aujourd'hui et ceci
provoque un certain nombre de
conséquences que nous n'avons pas encore
pleinement mesurés parce que nous sommes
dans une phase d'expérimentation au
compte de ces causes multiples
multidimensionnelle de la crise
financière j'ajouterai évidemment la
conversion universel partout dans le
monde à l'économie de marché donc
l'interconnexion de l'ensemble des très
grandes économies du monde
pas simplement
les pays avancés qui étaient eux mêmes
déjà interconnectés mais la chine
l'ensemble du bloc de l'est qui ont
évidemment eu aussi créé un certain
nombre disons deux caractéristiques de
l'économie financière internationale qui
était inexplorés puisqu'on ne les
connaissais pas auparavant
bref ces causes multiples ont provoqué
ce que j'observais modem il y un instant
comme étant une menace d'effondrement
systémique et nous avons connu je vous
propose une lecture de la crise en trois
étapes en trois phases en trois épisodes
le premier essai la crise des subprimes
comme on dit dans le jargon
à savoir une découverte qu'un certain
nombre de valeurs négociables était très
très mauvaise très médiocre alors
qu'elle était réputé très bonne ceci
s'est passé aux états unis et du point
de vu de l'intensité de la crise je
crois qu'on peut dater le début de cette
crise des subprimes pour ce qui nous
concerne les banques centrales de la
décision que nous avons prise à la
banque centrale européenne le 9 août
2007 lorsque voyant que notre marché
monétaire et est totalement bloqué et il
ne fonctionnait plus du tout nous avons
décidé de donner de la liquidité de
manière illimitée à taux fixe c'était un
taux de 4% à l'ensemble des banques
commerciales européennes
c'était la première grande décision dit
non standard et elle a marqué le début
de la crise financière internationale
dans son ton son premier épisode celui
des subprimes 9 août 2007 jusqu'à 15
septembre 2008
fin du premier épisode et début du
second épisode
lyman brothers dépose son bilan est là
alors nous avons un épisode gravissime
celui de la menace grave et immédiate
d'effondrement de l'ensemble du système
financier
effondrement non pas parce que lehman
brothers avait d'innombrables canaux de
communication avec l'ensemble des autres
grandes banques ou grandes institutions
financières au grand marché du monde
mais parce que l'ensemble des
participants du marché l'ensemble des
institutions financières mondiales se
sont dits en même temps au même instant
si une grande banque de wall street peut
déposer son bilan alors c'est que tout
le monde peut déposer son bilan toutes
les institutions toutes nos
contreparties et donc prenons
immédiatement les mesures appropriées
pour éviter de se trouver nous-mêmes
pris dans une tempête financière donc
rendons le plus liquide possible
l'ensemble de nos actifs
changeons complètement notre horizon
d'investissement
prenons encore en quelque sorte toutes
les décisions que l'on peut prendre
lorsque l'on redoute que tous les
marchés soient interrompus un moment ou
un autre lorsque l'on redoute que toutes
les contreparties tous les partenaires
avec lesquels on travaille
ordinairement puissent eux-mêmes être
défaillants comme ceci s'est passé dans
l'ensemble du monde à peu près en même
temps dans les quelques demi-journées
qui ont suivi l'effondrement de lehman
brothers vous pouvez imaginer quelles
ont été les conséquences ce que j'ai
observé moi même au niveau européen
comme mes collègues et notamment ben
bernanke et aux états unis et les autres
collègues au japon ou en angleterre nous
avons donc observé sous nos yeux un
effondrement ou une menace
d'effondrement gravissime
on a évité cet effondrement il a fallu
prendre des décisions très très
audacieuse qui n'était dans aucun manuel
et des décisions qui ne correspondaient
pas à l'évidence à ce que l'on pouvait
imaginer où on avait pu imaginer dans
des temps plus normaux cette décision ne
correspondaient à aucune décision aussi
audacieux cette teinture prises depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale
elles ont été prises et elles ont évité
l'effondrement du système évitant
l'effondrement du système
elles ont évité ce qui aurait été
probablement une grande dépression qui
dans mon esprit aurait pu être plus
grave que les événements que nous avons
connue en 1929 tellement la rapidité de
la contagion était grande et tellement
la menace était grave et immédiate
on n'a pas eu la grande dépression mais
on a eu une grande récession au niveau
de l'ensemble des pays avancés j'ai
mentionné et les banques centrales et je
suis prêt naturellement à redire là
dessus même si ce n'est pas votre sujet
principal
il faut que je mentionne les
gouvernements car il a fallu que les
gouvernements eux mêmes se mobilise de
manière tout à fait considérable on a
oublié d'ailleurs la mobilisation
gouvernementale maintenant parce qu'on a
évité la catastrophe et que cette
mobilisation
heureusement ne s'est pas transformé en
sinistres trop trop grave ou trop
important mais il faut avoir les ordres
de grandeur en tête pour éviter
l'effondrement du système les pays
avancés eux mêmes je prends mon quelques
exemples en europe ont dû mobiliser des
montants de risque du contribuable qui
ont été de l'ordre de 50 % du produit
intérieur brut pour certains pays 25%
pour d'autres 18,6 pour cent pour notre
propre pays et plusieurs centaines 2% à
vrai dire du produit intérieur brut pour
ceux qui ont été les plus menacées qui
était dans la situation la plus grave
ces chiffres sont très très
impressionnant
je pourrais citer des chiffres encore
plus impressionnant puisque au moment
absolument clé de la crise au moment de
son intensité la plus grande en réalité
tous les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
des grands pays avancés ont expliqué
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas y avoir de
dépôts de bilan d'entreprises
financières systémiques
chez eux ils ont été cru et c'est ce qui
a permis d'éviter l'effondrement du
système en termes de prise de risque
il s'agissait pas naturellement d'une
d'un risque légal d'un risque juridique
mais en termes de prise de risque
politique entre guillemets ceux ci
correspondait à plusieurs centaines de
bourses en du produit intérieur brut
puisque c'était en quelque sorte une
garantie politique générale donnée en
allemagne en angleterre en france aux
états unis à des institutions
financières dans les bilans eux mêmes se
représente un plusieurs pib ou un pib
avec plusieurs plusieurs entités
financières donc au total des montants
évidemment absolument colossaux alors
nous sommes dans une situation
complètement différente maintenant
naturellement l'ensemble des décisions
qui ont été prises et sur lesquels je ne
vais pas manqué de revenir dans vos
rangs répondre à vos questions ont
permis je crois d'avoir un système qui
est aujourd'hui plus solide
beaucoup moins fragile plus résilient
même s'il faut rester très prudent et
même si le temps n'est certainement pas
la complaisance
j'ajouterai que nous sommes en présence
de dinde le mécanisme qui eux mêmes ne
sont pas encore expérimenté mais à tout
le moins le sentiment est suffisamment
plus confiant au moment où je parle pour
que l'on puisse se placer dans un
contexte complètement différent on a
complètement changé de paradigme
depuis l'époque où
il fallait sauver les grands
établissements systémiques pour éviter
l'effondrement et la grande dépression
nous sommes maintenant sus au niveau de
la réflexion internationale des
décisions ou des orientations prises au
niveau mondial et au niveau européen
aussi bien qu'au niveau national en
présence de concepts comme si une
entreprise financière a des problèmes
eh bien il faut qu'on protège le
contribuable il faut que l'on organise
soit le redémarrage de l'entreprise sur
des bases saines soit sa liquidation
et dans tous les cas il faut mettre le
contribuable en quelque sorte en dernier
ressort et voir dans quel ordre
on demandera des efforts aux différentes
parties prenantes
donc nous avons totalement changé la
perspective et nous sommes maintenant
dans une perspective encore une fois de
liquidation organisée ou de reprises et
de redémarrages organisée avec des
décisions qui viennent d'être prises
pour certaines d'entre elles en europe
en particulier mais sur la base de
concepts internationaux qui ont été
discutées au niveau de l'économie
mondiale dans le cadre du g20 dans le
cadre du forum de stabilité du conseil
de stabilité financière et au niveau
européen
votre commission travaille au moment
même où sont prises un certain nombre de
décisions ou fait un certain nombre de
propositions précisément sur ces
questions de supervision bancaire au
niveau européen et de mécanisme de
liquidation de résolution comme on dit
en anglais au niveau européen la
dernière d'ailleurs
mesure le dernier point important est la
proposition de la commission qui ne fait
pas l'objet d'un consensus du tout pour
le moment qui devrait être discutée et
qui porte sur l'institution d'un
mécanisme de l'examen du redémarrage de
la reprise et le cas échéant de la
liquidation des institutions bancaires
au niveau européen la commission vient
de déposer sa propre proposition qui
sera examinée normalement avant la fin
de cette année monsieur le président je
m'arrête là parce que je vois que je
suis en train de dépasser les 10 minutes
que ma vie' ma vie est donné et je suis
très bien sûr répondre à toutes vos
questions
merci beaucoup de ses propos
introductifs je passe ce sens en tenant
la parole à eric bocquet et un merci
monsieur ou vers notre richesse cette
instruction extrêmement claire et
parfaitement structuré ma déception
prend personne
vous avez dit dans votre propos
liminaire le système que nous avions
créé j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
entendez par nous les institutions les
banques l'industrie financière en
général fin j'aimerais avoir une
précision sur le sens que vous attribuez
à ce pronom et dans l'est le deuxième
temps sur les causes multiples
extrêmement précise que vous analysez et
présenté comme étant les causes de cette
crise financière toujours à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui malheureusement vous citez
bien sûr là la dérégulation
l'amplification des bulles le rôle
qu'ont pu avoir les agences de notation
les modifications comptables spéculation
esprits à niveau les technologies
économie de marché interconnecté voilà
et vous ne citez à aucun moment le monde
de l'offshore qui est au coeur de notre
préoccupation est ce qu'est ce que ça
veut dire selon vous que ça n'a aucun
rôle dans cette des règles de régulation
financière aucune responsabilité dans
cette crise
ce monde ne vaut pas que complexe
très lourd en montant voilà quel est
votre sentiment sur ce point je
gouverneur quand j'ai dis nous je
voulais dire la communauté
internationale tout entière
l'ensemble des participants du du monde
tous ensemble je ne n'identifie pas de
responsable particulier nous avons
assisté depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale à une évolution extraordinaire
à la fois des technologies de de
l'économie internationalisé de la
finance internationale ise et s'éteint
c'est un phénomène qui est de nature
vraiment fondamental j'ai évoqué la
conversion à l'économie de marché d'une
très large partie du monde ça fait
partie d'une où j'ai évoqué en effet la
incertain nombre de d'éléments le
décisive je crois dans la déclenchement
de la crise
ça fait partie d'une ou le nous si vous
voulez je n'ai pas et je crois qu'il
faudrait se garder d' identifier un bouc
émissaire qui serait responsable de tous
parce que le bouc émissaire servirait à
comment dirais-je disculper tous les
autres or le problème est que chacun a
sa responsabilité nous avons réellement
expérimentés et nous avons vu dans cette
expérimentation que ce que nous avions
créé que beaucoup croyaient il faut voir
d'où l'on vient
je vais vous donner deux exemples le le
monde était si sûr qu'ils étaient
solides et résilients que lorsque les
deux directeurs généraux du fonds
monétaire international successifs
rodrigo des râteaux et dominique strauss
kahn ont été nommés il leur a été dit le
monde est maintenant suffisamment
solides pour qu' il n'y ait plus besoin
du fonds monétaire international pour
aider les pays
maintenant les pays eux-mêmes sont très
solides et bien entendu les pays avancés
au premier chef et les marchés
financiers fonctionne tellement bien que
si jamais il ya des besoins financiers
naturellement les marchés financiers
privait les l'ensemble disons d des du
système financier de nature privée va
pouvoir financer les pays sans qu'il
soit besoin de mobiliser le fonds
monétaire international c'est exactement
ce qui a été dit à rodrigo de rato puis
à dominique strauss kahn
c'est vous dire à quel point le plus le
monde entier et est et quel que soit je
dois dire les sensibilités dans les
principaux pays avancés
le monde entier était dans la croyance
qui s'est avéré extrêmement naïve que
nous étions dans un monde très solide je
me permets de dire avait quand même
prudents mais que les seules
institutions qui n'avaient pas
nécessairement ce sentiment est qu'ils
continuer à prêcher une certaine
prudence ou une certaine sagesse était
souvent les banques centrales j'en ai
moi-même fait l'expérimentation puisque
j'ai dans la quasi totalité de ma
carrière était considéré comme étant
trop prudent trop sage
prêchant trop la sagesse budgétaire ou
où la sagesse monétaire et 7
cet environnement ne s'est retournée
qu'avec le déclenchement de la crise
pour être pour être clair auparavant ce
qui était très prisé de manière presque
unanime c'était l'accommodation le fait
d'être aussi ouvert que possible aussi
accommodant que possible un peu un peu
dans tous les domaines offshore
je n'ai pas mentionné l'off shore comme
étant une cause principale de la crise
parce que je crois que c'est un des
éléments parmi d'autres auraient ils
auraient pu le mentionner
c'est plus encore que l'offshore je
dirais c'est là la négligence générale
en matière de contrôle de réglementation
et l'off shore mme par être l'un des
éléments l'un des points d'application
malheureusement important est
particulièrement dangereux de cette
attitude générale de négligence alors je
dois quand même dire que sur l'offshore
vous avez trois concepts qui à mon avis
sont de nature différente et qui
d'ailleurs ont été traité
internationalement à des moments
différents dans le temps vous avez l'off
shore en tant que entité se prêtant au
blanchiment de l'argent activités
criminelles et au financement du
terrorisme activités criminelles là la
communauté internationale s'est penché
sur ce dossier lors du sommet d
industrialiser de 1989 à paris
à vrai dire et j'étais moi même à
l'époque négociateurs et nous avons créé
à ce moment là le gafi auprès de l' ocde
avec comme objectif de combattre le
financement du terrorisme et le
blanchiment de l'argent donc des
activités criminelles
le gafi a été finalement la premier le
premier point d'application universelle
alors il n'était pas dirigée uniquement
sur l'offshore mais évidemment son point
d'applications privilégié et lé pays où
les entités qui était le plus éloigné
d'appliquer les règles internationales
élémentaire et en particulier celles qui
se prêtait enfin celles qui combattent
est résolument le terrorisme est là
et la criminalité organisée le
blanchiment de l'argent
un second élément qui est intervenu plus
tard a été celui de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale la fraude fiscale la
fraude elle même est une algue est un
délit par conséquent on peut considérer
par extension de la lutte contre le
blanchiment que là on avait déjà une
partie du problème traité mais l'évasion
elle-même n'est pas forcément un crime
ou un délit et elle a été reconnue
récemment par la communauté
internationale comme étant un problème
très important
puis un dernier point qui lui était
extrêmement important et qui est apparu
bien entendu avec la crise
internationale qui est celui de la
généralisation de règles de prudence
identique à toutes les entités mondiales
y compris les places offshore et ceci
évidemment est aussi relativement récent
la généralisation l'universalisation des
règles de prudence est un phénomène
relativement nouveau
la crise a permis de renforcer
formidablement les deux derniers points
jeu direct le lait le premier point
c'est à dire la lutte contre la
criminalité organisée le blanchiment et
le financement du terrorisme
comme vous le voyez remonte finalement
au début des années 90 après le sommet
de de paris de 1989
vous étiez à l'époque du démarrage de la
crise qu dont vous avez rappelé les
différentes étapes à la tête de la bce
avez vous été surpris d'abord de la
survenue de cette crise
et puis le son ampleur ensuite de ces
développements ou aviez-vous perçu le
part aux activités de par votre
connaissance de la finance
internationale
des signes avant coureurs de ce risque
potentiel
j'ai comme tous mes collègues j'ai parlé
des banquiers centraux
j'ai eu le privilège d'être à bâle le
président et certaines des réunion des
banquiers centraux notamment le la
réunion de l'économie mondiale et je
rendais compte régulièrement de ses
réunion de banquiers centraux qui
n'était pas spécialement suivi à vrai
dire par la presse internationale où les
médias mais qui permettait de faire le
point et je dois dire que l'expression
qui était celle de cette communauté de
banquiers centraux notamment en 2006 et
2007 était que nous avions sentiment
qu'il y avait une sous-estimation
général des risques dans l'économie
internationale
nous voyons des marges extrêmement
faibles nous voyons des d une volatilité
excessivement faibles également des
primes de risque très très peu élevé qui
dénotait de la part de l'ensemble disons
du fonctionnement de l'économie
internationale l'économie financière
internationale une appréciation
extrêmement optimistes sur le niveau des
risques et nous pensions qu'il était de
notre devoir de le signaler à la fois
bien entendu directement chacun chez
nous à l'ensemble de nos institutions
mais aussi sur le plan international
j'ai moi même fait la première page du
'financial times' en janvier 2007 sur un
avertissement sur la sous-estimation que
nous que je voyais des risques donc
quand les dans l'économie internationale
donc lorsque le premier épisode que
j'évoquais c'est à dire celui des
subprimes est arrivé il est apparu un
certain nombre de mes collègues comme à
moi même comme étant le début de la
correction nécessaire compte tenu du
fait que il y avait eu sous-estimation
des risques et d'ailleurs dans un
premier temps c'est effectivement ce
qu'on a observé ces marges qui était
beaucoup trop faible ces primes de
risque qui était beaucoup trop faible
ce sont élevés et de manière d'ailleurs
assez brutale presque en un jour en une
journée nous avons vu sur notre marché
monétaire les primes montée assez
considérablement et disons à peu près
une année s'est écoulée de d'août 2007
septembre 2008 pendant laquelle nous
avons observé un certain de correction
sur une série de marchés
puis sont arrivés les premières
évolutions très graves d'un certain
nombre d'institutions bear stearns aux
états unis freddie mac et fannie mae et
lehman bros
et là on a vu que nous allons nous
étions en présence d'un système qui
marquait une instabilité potentielle
considérable
alors là je dois dire je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait eu ici ou là de
d'institutions ultra lucide qui ait pu
dire dans le fond ce que nous allons
expérimenter maintenant c'est la menace
grave et immédiat de l'effondrement du
système mais tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que lorsque la décision a été
prise de laisser tomber lehman brothers
nous mêmes à la banque centrale
européenne n'avons pas hésité une
seconde
en considérant que nous étions en
présence de phénomènes d'une
extraordinaire gravité
ce qui n'a pas été le cas partout dans
le monde ne serait ce que parce que
il y avait encore le sentiment que le
l'ensemble du système financier mondial
pourrait digérer même un dépôt de bilan
aussi monumental que celui de lehman
brothers en somme il y avait dans
beaucoup de l'analyse surestimation de
la résilience du système
j'ai dis qu'aujourd'hui on pouvait
parler de l'équivalent du dépôt de bilan
de lehman brothers on en organisant la
la liquidation de manière aussi
raisonnable que possible et que ceci est
d'une certaine manière la preuve que le
nous ne considérons pas d'une manière
générale que le système est aussi
fragile qu'il l'était auparavant
mais j'ai aussi dit qu'il ne fallait pas
être complaisant donc en réalité nous ne
savons pas très bien quelle est la
solidité ou l'absence de solidité du
système financier mondial dans lequel
nous sommes nous sommes nous l'avons
connu des succès prodigieux au niveau
mondial au niveau international mais ces
succès ont une contrepartie
c'est que nous explique nous explorons
disant des territoires qui sont inconnus
encore aujourd'hui
oui selon werner je vais vous poser une
question vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
l'extrait l'extrême rapidité des
décisions sur les marchés qui sont
favorisés d'ailleurs par an les
nouvelles techniques de de communication
est ce que si on en faisait le bilan de
cette de ce progrès technique
est-ce qu'il sert vraiment la vraie vie
économique ou est ce qui sert la
spéculation
c'est une question que les les autorités
les banques centrales bien sûr et les
autorités prudentielles doivent se poser
en permanence et qui se pose de manière
particulièrement aiguë lorsqu'on est en
présence de 7 ce trading ultra rapide
dans lequel les fractions infinitésimale
de seconde compte pour gagner telle ou
telle position et et être plus plus plus
efficace que ses partenaires
nous explorons des territoires qui sont
totalement nouveaux le fait de se
déplacer d'une centaine de mètres pour
être plus proche de la machine centrale
qui fait fonctionner tel ou tel marché
parce qu'avec en gagnant 100 m on gagne
les 100 m que met la lumière pour
parcourir ces 100 m en termes de temps
et quelque chose d'absolument
inimaginable que nous ne pensions pas en
fait avoir expérimenté mais sur lequel
nous je dois dire la quasi totalité des
places réfléchissent en ce moment le
problème est que lorsque vous faites des
percées technologiques elles sont
immédiatement exploité et que vous ne
pouvez pas partir du principe qu'il
qu'on peut arrêter la technologie donc
il faut essayer de la maîtrise et du
mieux possible je serai et je ne
répondrai pas à votre question la
technologie est capable du meilleur
comme du pire comme la langue d'esope
pensez-vous sur un autre domaine que les
grands acteurs financiers recourt
souvent en tout cas assez souvent la
confiscation de l'information et que les
superviseurs sont en mesure de remédier
à cette situation
c'est tout problème de l'efficacité des
superviseurs je crois que là le réveil
brutal de la crise pour l'ensemble des
superviseurs du monde entier a été de ce
point de vue là extraordinairement utile
certaines supervision était fondé sur le
principe selon lequel le superviseur
n'allait pas
sur place ne contrôlez pas sur place les
entités financières se contentait de
regarder sur pièce ce que les diverses
banques ou les institutions financières
lui envoyait et le cas échéant bien sûr
se reposait sur les audits qui était
fait par les auditeurs traditionnels
cette conception de la surveillance
prudentielle a été totalement balayé par
la crise l'idée selon laquelle
maintenant bien entendu la supervision
suppose d'aller sur place et non pas
simplement d'examiner les dossiers sur
pièce dell est sur place pour regarder
sur place pour interroger tous les
acteurs sur place
et pour se faire une idée aussi complète
que possible de la culture et de la
manière dont l'entité pratique sa propre
activité avec une culture sous jacente
qui peut être une culture de respect de
la réglementation ou au contraire une
culture de biaisant avec la
réglementation tout cela est considéré
maintenant comme faisant partie des
bonnes pratiques sans sans qu'il y est
je dois dire de contestation donc je
dirais que sous le choc de la crise
là le concept même de surveillance
prudentielle à ses concerts et
l'exercice de la surveillance
prudentielle acp s'est complètement
changé dramatiquement changé j'ai une
question de cannes avec l'écho vous
poser une question
le gouverneur oui et moi deux petites
questions
d'abord la première comment de lehman
brothers pourquoi le gouvernement
américain at-il laissé tomber lehman
brothers et la deuxième comment pensez
vous qu'il soit possible de lutter
efficacement contre ces places offshore
qui aujourd'hui on sent mais content
nous pose de terribles difficultés le la
question sur l'attitude du gouvernement
américain s'agissant de lehman brothers
est évidemment une question une
importance considérable sur laquelle les
américains eux même et ré toute la
démocratie américaine s'est penché
considérablement je vais vous donner ma
ma propre compréhension ma propre
interprétation de ce qui s'est passé
mais lehman brothers et la quatrième
entité que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
après trois autres il y à eut d'abord
bear stearn qui a connu des difficultés
à vicitmes et qui a pu être sauvée par
une intervention privé mais une
intervention privé considérablement
facilitée par les autorités américaines
est donc devant en effet la gravité des
événements qui pouvait se passer devant
le l'importance de la contagion qu'il
pouvait y avoir il y avait eu consensus
au sein de l'administration américaine
et de la banque centrale pour considéré
qu'il était opportun de faciliter cette
reprise c'était une reprise privé n'y a
pas eu d'argent public
elle avait quand même été très critiqués
en disant nous sommes dans une économie
de marché dans une économie de marché il
faut laisser les mauvaises gestions être
puni nous ne sommes pas dans un système
de type soviétique où il n'y avait aucun
dépôt de bilan par construction donc le
propre de l'économie de marché c'est que
quand on est mauvais gestionnaires on
abandonne la partie et on est remplacé
par d'autres
cette critique là était très forte aux
états unis très forte et donc elle a
posé de sérieux problèmes à
l'administration américaine de l'époque
sur le plan du débat public
on a eu ensuite freddie mac et fannie
mais qui sont deux entités spécialisées
dans le financement du logement qui elle
alors alors que berne étaient 10 en une
une banque d'investissement mais réputé
peut-être plutôt conservatrices comme
entité la freddie mac et fannie mae
avait la réputation d'être plutôt de
l'autre côté descente de la sensibilité
puisque spécialisée dans le logement et
dans le logement des plus pauvres et là
alors l'administration américaine a dû
se mobiliser et à sauver d'une
catastrophe qui aurait été réellement
absolument abominable
ces entités avec de l'argent public
et cet argent public a été considéré à
nouveau comme étant très critiquable
pourquoi mobiliser l'argent du
contribuable pour empêcher des entités
mal géré je reprends le débat public
américain de ne s'effondre et voyez en
simplifiant outrageusement critiques de
droite d'un côté critique de gauche de
l'autre convergent pour dire vous ne
devez pas d'enfants nés dans une
économie dans laquelle vous ne devez pas
à intervenir en permanence pour
renflouer telle ou telle entité
c'est après c2 c3 expérience et ses
critiques venant d'un peu tous les côtés
de l'aidant dans le disons l'échiquier
de sensibilité américain que vient la
quatrième entité pour laquelle il n'y a
pas de solution privée en tout cas il
s'avère qu'il n'y a pas de solution
privée et là mon sentiment est que le
l'exécutif américain s'est dit mais je
ne peux pas continuer cette séquence de
sauvetage qui est à l' chaque fois très
critiqué et dont je ne sais pas quand
elle va s'arrêter parce que si nos amis
de l'exécutif américain avait sauver
lehman brothers il aurait eu
immédiatement derrière à sauver et hadji
et s'il avait sauvé et hadji il aurait
immédiatement eu derrière le sauvetage
de cité et et cetera et cetera
et donc s'il on rationalise ce qui s'est
passé ex post
on peut dire d'une certaine manière ce
que nous avions en face de nous et nous
sommes payés tous pour le savoir c'était
un risque systémique majeur un système
tout entier qui était en cause
le l'arrêt de l'effondrement
séquentielle du système devait être lui
même de nature systémique et ne pouvait
pas se limiter à une série 1 définie
dans le temps de sauvetage qui
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est passé
puisque lorsque le dépôt de bilan de
lehman brothers a prouvé qu'ils avaient
des conséquences absolument redoutable
sur l'ensemble du système alors très
vite
l'exécutif américain a présenté un
programme ayant l'ambition d' arrêter
l'effondrement systémique qui a été le
programme tarp qui d'ailleurs a été
refusée par le parlement américain
dans un premier temps ce qui montre à
quel point la l'élite politique
américaine de quelques sensibilités que
ce soit et être au début inconscientes
de la gravité des événements et on
comprend mieux alors rétrospectivement
qu'effectivement tous les sauvetages
successifs étaient très critiqués parce
que personne n'avait en tête
en tout cas pas dans la large opinion
américaine que c'est le système tout
entier qui était encore
lorsqu'il est apparu après un temps
suffisant et notamment jeu de dire
l'effondrement de l'ensemble des valeurs
boursières que le problème était
gravissime et que nous étions
effectivement en présence d'un risque
systémique qui était en train de se
transformer en sinistre sous nos yeux
alors le programme tarp a été votée par
le congrès des états unis et on a on a
eu affaire à la première grande
opération d'arrêt du de cette menace
d'effondrement systémique
je me suis concentré sur les états unis
la question était sur les états unis
on peut dire d'une certaine manière que
sous des formes diverses
l'ensemble finalement des pays avancés
on tue eux mêmes à faire face à un défi
de même nature et ils ont fait face
finalement dans des conditions qui ont
été extrêmement difficile mais qui était
je crois nécessaire évidemment merci
beaucoup je vais passer la parole à deux
d'entre nous si vous voulez bien pour
regrouper les questions encore que on
fera sur ce point comme vous le
souhaiterez nous allons d'abord avoir la
question de notre collègue colin puis la
question madame des ego le gouverneur je
suis bien entendu ce que vous avez dit
sur la supervision prudentielle qui
consiste maintenant notamment allés sur
place et n'ont pas à être simplement un
examen de documents alors parallèlement
à ça moi je dois vous dire que ici nous
sommes un certain nombre dans cette
commission denquête assez surpris du
nombre
la création de filiales par les banques
l'exemple on nous a cité paribas qui a
300 filiales
donc nous pensons qu'il ya là peut être
un manque de transparence
évident au travers de cette volonté de
création de structures multiples
notamment j'ai cru comprendre que le
contrôle
je crois que ça l'a nourri nos talents
qui vous a parlé de ça que le contrôle
porte sur les comptes consolidés et donc
porte sur les soldes et non pas sur les
opérations elles-mêmes et en plus on
nous a dit d'ailleurs quand on ne
pouvait pas aller regarder un peu
territorialement les opérations à
l'étranger
un don qu'il faut voilà c'est
effectivement c'est contrôle prudentiel
ne peuvent se faire que sur le
consolider et donc je le redis
uniquement sur les soldes
dans cette situation je pense que les
gens vous la connaissez moi j'aimerais
j'aimerais bien connaître votre avis
là-dessus parce que je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un risque avéré que c'est
c'est peut-être une des unes des
questions fondamentales par rapport à
cette situation aujourd'hui qui n'est
pas réglementée qui n'est pas et qui
inhérents à ces à ces situations de
l'offshore voilà donc je voudrais avoir
vraiment votre sentiment sur ce match
évidemment c'est une question très
importante de votre commission je ne
sais bien se concentre sur l'offshore
mais vous le voyez bien le problème se
pose pour tous les pays sans aucune
exception les pays européens
nous avons des pays européens plus ou
moins coopératifs le luxembourg et le et
l'autriche sont moins coopératifs que
d'autres dans certains domaines
particulièrement dans le domaine fiscal
le monde est fait de pays avancé de pays
de l'émergence de pays en développement
ils sont plus ou moins coopératifs et
puis nous avons les toutes petites
entités qui ont une franchise
particulière parce que étant négligente
étant laxiste et en complaisante à
l'égard du financement criminels ou
étant complaisante à l'égard de de la
fraude fiscale elle nous posent des
problèmes particuliers mais je pense
qu'il faut bien voir que nous avons un
problème beau
ou plus générale que le seul problème de
l'off shore stricto sensu ce que s'il ne
s'agissait que de cela et si nous avions
le consensus de l'ensemble des pays
après tout il ne s'agit que d'un certain
nombre de petites entités et qui n'ont
donc beaucoup d'ailleurs sans sous
juridiction anglaise ou sous juridiction
pour certaines d'entre elles américaine
est donc le problème ne serait pas me
semble utile
forcément le plus le plus grave mais il
est grave naturellement parce que c'est
quand même là effectivement qu'on a
trouvé le plus de juridictions non
coopératives
alors je ne veux pas vous dire que tout
va bien j'ai dit qu'il ne fallait pas
être complaisant et que je n'étais pas
sûr du tout que nous soyons maintenant
dans un système qui est suffisamment
sûre pour qu' on puisse le considérer
comme étant résistant aux chocs si je
puis dire
mais le fait qu'en 2009 il y es tu là
l'invention disons du concept de
juridictions non coopératives dans les
trois dimensions que j'ai évoqués c'est
à dire la dimension criminelle
financement du terrorisme blanchiment la
dimension prudentielles et la dimension
fiscale avec dans chaque cas
l'identification d'un responsable
international chargé si je puis dire de
faire la police inquiets le gafi créé en
1989 le conseil de stabilité financière
qui a été renforcée à l'occasion de la
crise et le forum mondial de l'eau c d e
sur le plan sur le plan fiscal
ce sont quand même si vous voulez
maintenant on a un consensus émergent un
concept qui existe et des outils en
principe dans le reste c'est une
question d'énergie et de détermination
finalement des principaux pays du monde
si l'on publie réellement la liste des
états qui n'appliquent pas les standards
internationaux et auquel l'ensemble de
la communauté internationale demande
d'appliquer les standards internationaux
il me semble que nous nous aurons la
preuve alors qu'effectivement
l'ensemble de la communauté internet
c'est un problème qui ne peut être
réglée qu'au niveau mondial est
déterminé suffisamment déterminée pour
le problème que vous soulevez clairement
nous sommes bien obligés dès lors qu'il
y à des entités internationales qui ont
des filiales et pas simplement des
succursales si ce sont des succursales
c'est le pru le l'autorité prudentielles
nationale qui a la compétence est donc
là il n'y a pas de problème la réponse à
votre question est aisée et il faut s'en
féliciter
mais un très grand nombre de pays
veulent être maîtres chez eux et ils ne
se sont pas des pays nécessairement
qu'ils le font pour pratiquer la fraude
l'évasion ou la défense d'activité qui
est enfin là la localisation d'activités
criminelles sont les pays qui veulent
être simplement les maîtres chez eux et
donc ils peuvent exiger effectivement
d'avoir des filiales pour que ce soit
leur autorité prudentielle qui puisse
exercer le contrôle et la nous retombons
dans ce que je veux je viens de dire ses
terres il faut que partout dans le monde
on puisse avoir l'application des mêmes
standards application des mêmes
standards contrôlé par une entité ayant
cette responsabilité au niveau de
l'économie internationale elle même
merci beaucoup
alors notre collègue colin je n'ai pas
oublié merci monsieur le président
monsieur le gouverneur merci d'éclairer
notre commission de votre compétence et
surtout de votre expérience vous avez
rappelé que vous étiez tout au long de
cette crise au début en tout cas en
première ligne alors est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire justement qu en tant
qu observateur privilégié qu'elles sont
les grandes zones de plus forte opacité
financière sur la planète ce que vous
avez pu constater ensuite dans les
recommandations de la banque centrale
européenne sur l'assainissement des
finances publiques
c'est le site telus l'occasion de
mentionner parmi les réformes
structurelles nécessaires des mesures
destinées à harmoniser les prélèvements
obligatoires pouvez-vous répondre aux
questions et ensuite
avez vous construit comment lutter
contre la concurrence fiscale
dommageable et à lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale internationale à toutes ces
questions peut-être je pourrais ajouter
une pour éclairer notre commission mais
qui pas directement liée à notre mission
mais pensez vous que l'euro est
définitivement hors de danger
je vous remercie monsieur le gouverneur
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
première question nous nous vivons sur
longue période
une évolution donc de transformation du
monde je fais remonter encore une fois
la première préoccupation vis-à-vis
d'entités obscur d'entités dissimulant
leurs activités au niveau international
au niveau d'un consensus de 2 la
canadien de la communauté internationale
comme comme vous l'avez entendu à 89
1989 donc c'est un processus qui va me
semble-t-il être formidablement accéléré
à cause de la crise que nous que nous
venons de connaître
mais il est clair que l'an les endroits
dans le monde où nous avions la plus
grande opacité était à l'évidence un
certain nombre de places offshore qui
faisaient commerce finalement de leur
opacité vis-à-vis mal soyons clairs en
particulier de ceux qui avaient des
activités criminelles pas forcément
d'ailleurs de ceux qui pratiquaient
simplement l'évasion
ce cas au sein même des pays avancés au
sein même de pays parfaitement
respectable compte tenu de ce qu était à
l'époque le droit international le droit
des gens vous aviez quelques pays que
nous connaissons bien qu'ils sont très
proches de nous d'ailleurs
qui en effet considéré comme faisant
partie de leur culture d'être opaque sur
le plan fiscal et ce n'est qu'assez
récemment que ceux ci changent et est en
train de changer sous nos yeux et donc
puisque salon mais au sein même de la
zone de l'union européenne nous avions
des pratiques de ce genre qui sont en
train de disparaître complètement et il
faut s'en féliciter mais qui était
considéré il faut bien se mettre à la
place des différentes cultures qui était
considéré comme aussi fondamental que
certains éléments de leur culture auquel
il était extrêmement attachés on l'a vu
dans un pays qui est limitrophe tout
récemment
mais c'est en train de changer ça change
de manière extrêmement rapide et
évidemment il faut s'en féliciter
ailleurs qu'en europe
vous avez vous aviez encore beaucoup de
pays qui en effet se prêtait à cette
obscurité dont je ne veux pas faire moi
même
la liste comme je l'aï dit je
souhaiterais qu'il y ait de telles
listes et que nous puissions établir les
listes de ce dont nous considérons que
ce sont des juridictions non
coopératives
au moment où nous parlons j'espère bien
que cela sera le cas
deuxièmement assainissement des finances
publiques
vous savez j'ai moi même de manière
constante demandé qu'on applique la loi
qu'on applique le traité qu'on applique
la législation secondaire du traité et
la banque centrale européenne ne prétend
pas inventé la loi européenne ou le
la législation secondaire ce que j'ai
énormément regretter énormément je veux
dire publiquement et à plusieurs
reprises c'est que on n'applique pas le
pacte de stabilité et de croissance
toute ma vie professionnelle j'ai
expliqué que le pacte de stabilité de
croissance et est fondamental parce que
nous étions très audacieux en créant une
monnaie unique que nous avions une
monnaie unique mais que où que nous
allions avoir une monnaie unique mais
que nous n'avions pas de fédération
politique achevée certainement pas que
nous n'avions pas de budget fédéral et
par conséquent ayant une monnaie unique
il fallait évidemment avoir un cadre
pour faire fonctionner convenablement la
monnaie unique
ceci n'a pas été considéré hélas comme
allant de soi y compris par notre propre
pays y compris par l'allemagne y compris
par l'italie et ma première bataille si
je puis dire lorsque j'ai été nommé
président de la banque centrale
européenne a consisté à rompre des
lances pour le pacte de stabilité et de
croissance
donc je le mentionne cela en passant si
vous voulez le problème a été que même
le respect des règles qui avaient été
fixés et qui était dans le traité a été
extrêmement difficile sur
l'harmonisation des fiscalités
l'harmonisation des prélèvements
obligatoires
je sais combien notre pays y est attaché
mais je crois qu'il ya un malentendu et
je me permets de le dire en toute
simplicité
il faut bien financer ses dépenses
quand on dépense beaucoup sur la longue
durée
il faut avoir à peu près autant de
recettes que de dépenses ou alors c'est
que quelqu'un est prêt à financer la
différence et l'expérience a montré que
personne en tout cas pas de d'entités
bénévoles en extérieur n'était prêt à
financer indéfiniment une différence
entre les dépenses et les recettes
donc le niveau de vos prélèvements le
niveau de votre fiscalité dépend en
dernière analyse
du niveau que votre pays jugent
appropriée notre pays comme tous les
autres jugent approprié en matière de
dépenses les recettes ne peuvent pas
être indépendante des dépenses c'est
aussi simple que ça on ne peut pas
forcer un pays qui estime qu' il ne faut
pas dépenser trop à avoir des excédents
budgétaires absolument gigantesque par
sur l'autel si je puis dire de
l'harmonisation des prélèvements
obligatoires ou de l'harmonisation
fiscale et de la même manière évidemment
on ne peut pas dire un pays qui veut
dépenser en proportion de son produit
intérieur brut beaucoup de dépense
publique qu'il doit être en déficit en
permanence parce que ce pauvre pays
alors n'aurait personnes pour le
financer donc je n'insiste là dessus je
crois qu'on ne peut pas traiter le
problème de l'harmonisation des recettes
fiscales ou l'harmonisation des
prélèvements obligatoires
si on ne traite pas celui de
l'harmonisation des dépenses manière
générale et je sais que c'est pas très
populaire de dire ça mais après tout
j'ai été banquier central pendant
suffisamment de temps pour pouvoir dire
des choses qui ne sont pas très
populaires mais j'insiste beaucoup nous
sommes nous mêmes
le pays qui au sein de la zone euro au
sein de la zone euro a le plus de
dépenses publiques en proportion du
produit intérieur brut et au sein de
l'europe en général il y en a deux nous
et le danemark
c'est une position que nous n'avions pas
du tout auparavant c'est pas du tout
dans les chromosomes français en 1973
donc au moment du premier choc pétrolier
nos dépenses publiques en proportion du
produit intérieur brut étaient
inférieures aux dépenses publiques des
allemands et inférieures aux dépenses
publiques des anglais et donc nous
étions l'un des pays qui dépense est le
moins en proportion du pib
donc je crois qu' il y a eu si vous
voulez une évolution de notre pays
presqu'à son à son insu qui nous a
conduits d'une position qui était très
bonne pour la croissance et la création
d'emplois une position qui est beaucoup
moins bonne pour la croissance et la
création d'emplois
et le pays auquel je ne comparerai le
plus aujourd'hui serait le la suède
parce que la suède a eu à peu près la
même évolution
elle est même arrivé à un montant de
dépenses publiques en portions du pib
supérieur au nôtre
et puis elle a fait un effort sur
elle-même et elle elle a pu abaisser son
sa dépense publique en proportion du pib
de 10 % entier et elle s'en est trouvée
est dans une meilleure situation
je prends le temps la troisième question
vous avez posé qui est l'euro l'euro et
est un tel symbole que il me semble que
le vous l'avez utilisé en pensant zone
euro en pensant intégrité de la zone
euro parce que l'euro lui-même en tant
que monnaie a prouvé pendant toute la
crise une capacité de se protéger
lui-même contre la crise ya pas eu de
cri crise de change dans cette crise
dramatique
au contraire les seules remarques qu'on
a pu faire sur le roux qu'on fait sur
l'euro de temps en temps c'est il est
trop solide ce qui veut dire que l
inspire confiance
il a constamment préserver la confiance
et préserver son propre crédit depuis le
9 août 2007 depuis le début de la crise
telle que je la situer dans le temps
l'euro a été très solide
je ne dis pas qu'il a été trop solide
jeudi que l'euro finalement a rempli la
tâche qui lui avait été donné par les
démocraties européennes
on y en avait dix à la banque centrale
préserver la stabilité des prix est en
gros nous avons préserver la stabilité
des prix
exactement comme on le faisait
d'ailleurs en france avant l'euro avec
une définition qui était la même moins
de 2% proche de 2%
et à vrai dire sur 14 ans la hausse des
prix a été de 2 0 3% au niveau de
l'ensemble de la zone euro donc pour 333
millions d'habitants
ce qui est un résultat évidemment
conforme à ce que les démocraties nous
avait demandé de faire nos démocraties
est aussi un résultat je dois dire qui
explique pourquoi la stabilité monétaire
est demeuré pendant tout le temps de la
crise alors si la question est est ce
que la zone euro dans son intégrité va
demeurer
je dirai ce n'était pas le sentiment de
l'ensemble des observateurs pendant un
certain nombre de mois
depuis là le troisième épisode de la
crise est à dire le moment où la crise
s'est transformée en crise des risques
souverains et où l'épicentre de la crise
mondiale s'est déplacé pour arriver en
europe et plus particulièrement dans la
zone euro je dois dire que depuis
maintenant un an
le sentiment général de tous les
observateurs et que quatre éléments ont
joué un rôle essentiel pour stabiliser
l'intégrité ce que j'appelais
l'intégrité de la zone euro le premier
élément c'est que les pays qui s'était
très mal géré on fait de très grands
progrès l'heureux leur balance des
paiements courants qui était très très
négative pour les cinq pays qui ont été
attaqués à -8 % du produit intérieur
brut en 2008 2009 est maintenant proche
de zéro nous avons eu un renforcement de
la gouvernance économique et budgétaire
de l'ensemble de la zone euro qui a été
très important avec la le renforcement
du pacte de stabilité et de croissance
l'union bancaire qui fait partie
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière de
votre sujet
et puis bien entendu nous avons eu la
démonstration qu aucun pays ne
souhaitait expulsé tel ou tel autre pays
en difficulté avec des décisions qui ont
été observées dans le monde entier comme
signalant une détermination politico
stratégique de préserver l'intégrité de
la zone euro et il y a eu une action de
la banque centrale européenne qui après
avoir démontré à deux reprises et
j'étais alors président que on pouvait
intervenir sur les marchés sur les
crises sur les valeurs du trésor dans
certaines conditions et pour maintenir
préserver le dirait le le transfert
correct la politique monétaire à
l'ensemble des pays de la zone
il y a eu la nouvelle décision prise par
la banque centrale européenne dix ans il
y à une conditionnalité approprié et si
l'ensemble de la communauté de la zone
euro démontre qu'elle qu'elle est
sérieuse lorsqu'elle veut marquer sa
solidarité
alors nous mêmes nous pouvons intervenir
je pense que ce sont ces quatre raisons
qui expliquent que en effet vu d'asie
vue des etats-unis vu du reste du monde
l'intégrité de la zone euro paraît
solide
en tout état de cause la zone euro va
s'agrandir
ce qui est une marque de solidité bien
entendu elle va passer comme vous le
savez de 17 pays à 18 pays et de 332
millions d'habitants à 335 millions
d'habitants au début de l'année
prochaine ce qui ne veut pas dire que
tout est réglé au contraire à mes yeux
nous sommes au milieu du gué et encore
énormément de choses à faire avec la
plus grande détermination possible mais
cela prouve que ce à tout le moins
qu'ils pensaient que tout cela était
très fragile avait sous-estimé ce que
j'appellerai notre résident
le nouveau signifiant l'ensemble des
organes de la zone euro gouverneur avant
de passer la parole à 1 pour l'année
dernière flot de questions à notre
rapporteur je vais vous poser une
question que qui ne mettent aspiré par
un propos qui a été tenu par dominique
strauss kahn lorsque nous l'avons
interrogé lorsque l'âme on dise youn est
ici même il a eu sept
cette phrase enfin je vous livre cela
même en substance le système bancaire
ces outils chez produit il ya rien à
dire
ce n'est pas le système bancaire qui a
failli c'est les hommes avec peut-être
quelques caractères animaux pour
reprendre le qualificatif et il a eu
cette expression enfin cette comparaison
on peut pas reprocher à l'industrie
automobile et les accidents sur sur les
routes
est ce que vous pensez vous également
que le système bancaire ne mérite aucune
réforme que nous aucune amélioration et
que ce sont que les sommes qu'ils le
font déraper si j'ose dire pour rester
dans la comparaison automobile
et si vous ne pensez pas ça qu'est ce
que vous suggérez riez soit au niveau
européen soit même au niveau français la
condition bien sûr que ça ne le pénalise
pas dans la concurrence général qui
existe dans ce domaine
priez personnellement nous avons
clairement jeu disons que l'inspiration
de ce qu'a pu dire votre votre
interlocuteur était certainement de dire
ne faites pas de l'industrie bancaire un
bouc émissaire et cela je le partage
entièrement comme je vous ai dit c'est
le système tout entier qui a prouvé une
faiblesse inacceptable
mais si vous trouvez un bouc-émissaire
quelque part vous disculper tous les
autres or je dirai tout doit être
améliorée sans exception et bien entendu
aussi les banques
d'ailleurs c'est ce que la communauté
internationale a fait avec une très
grande force
nous avons incroyablement renforcer les
exigences en capital pour l'ensemble des
banques du monde
formidablement on nous ne sommes plus du
tout dans le même univers de d'exigence
à l'égard des banques
nous avons généralisé les ratios de
levier de de pourcentage entre le
capital et l'ensemble disons les bilans
des banques
nous avons multiplié les exigences à
leur égard joly dit les concept même de
surveillance prudentielle en changer le
renforcement de la surveillance
prudentielle a été considérablement
renforcée le il n'y a pas de pays
avancés au monde dans lequel il n'y ait
eu de transformation des institutions
chargées de surveiller les banques avec
des transformations extrêmement profonde
en europe bien entendu où l'on va
confier à la banque centrale européenne
des responsables
m auprès de la banque centrale
européenne les responsabilités qu'ils
n'y étaient pas encore et je pourrais
citer les états unis je pourrais citer
l'angleterre donc je dois dire que là le
diagnostic de la communauté
internationale a été que nous avions
nous devions absolument renforcer
formidablement l'ensemble nos banques
il fallait renforcer aussi toutes les
infrastructures de marché qu'il fallait
ne pas hésiter à avoir vis-à-vis
notamment de l'ensemble des dérivés de
toutes natures des exigences que nous
n'avions pas auparavant parce que l'idée
s'était accréditée idée fausse que
spontanément l'ensemble de ses marchés
devaient fonctionner de manière optimale
donc vous voyez je je dirais certes
faire des banques
un bouc émissaire serait une très très
grave erreur en même temps clairement
comme tout le reste du système financier
international
il est parfaitement légitime et
nécessaire et d'ailleurs ça a été à la
fois le diagnostic de la communauté
internationale et là les décisions qui
ont été prises ont été dans le sens d'un
renforcement de l'ensemble des banques
et des institutions
alors bien entendu tout cela repose sur
l'idée qu'il y à un traitement égal de
l'ensemble des institutions dans le
monde que nous ne nous livrons pas à une
compétition à qui sera le plus laxiste
comme ça a été le cas dans le passé à
qui arbitrera le mieux possible en étant
complaisant à l'égard de ces
institutions financières pour avoir les
activités les marchés etc pour pour
votre commission je dirais l'un des
dangers français à mon avis et d'oublier
que l'ensemble du système financier
finance l'économie que son financement
d'économie annie croissance ni création
d'emplois et que donc il faut être très
très attentif à ce que le système
fonctionne du mieux possible en étant
sain en étant au haut niveau de l'état
de l'art mondial dans les conditions les
meilleures possibles parce que
là aussi on rejoint cette idée si on
fait du système financier du système
bancaire un bouc émissaire alors on
risque de tuer ce qui est un des
éléments de la prospérité
j'ajouterai que le seul emploi dans le
secteur financier dans les pays avancés
est un enjeu très important est qu'il
est très important d'être capable
d'avoir à la fois la meilleure
surveillance prudentielle possible
inspirant la meilleure confiance
possible pour les entités qui peuvent
choisir de s'installer sur les places
financières qui sont toutes en
compétition comme il est probablement
normale dans des économies de marché et
donc je plaiderai volontiers pour la
place financé places financières
européennes disons les places
financières de la zone euro en
considérant que pour la prospérité de la
zone euro et l'emploi dans la zone euro
le monde en effet de l'industrie
financière et est un enjeu considérable
je vais laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur qui ne pardonnera
certainement d'avoir grappillé deux
cents ans
non mais très brièvement sur le
président de tout pardonner
une dernière question simplement sur le
financement de l'économie réelle par les
banques
malheureusement le constat a été fait
ces dernières années que la part du
financement consacré à l'économie réelle
était plutôt en régression et ce qui
n'est pas sans poser de questions mais
plus généralement sur le rôle de la bce
vous parlez de nouvelles responsabilités
est ce que dans ses responsabilités
nouvelles il y aurait une réflexion de
la bsu en tant que tel sur la résolution
des problèmes posés par love shop ce que
nous vous avez évoqué les dépenses des
états qui est juste mais nous de l'autre
côté nous sommes en quête en deux mots
également de recettes et donc l'évasion
fiscale vous savez ces deux-là recettes
conséquentes
on aurait tort de ne pas s'y intéresser
donc est ce que dans l'émission nouvelle
enfin les responsablités nouvelle de la
blessure est prévu ce genre de réflexion
lapin la fiscalité d'une manière
générale n'est pas du ressort de la
banque centrale dit des autorités
prudentielles
il se trouve que la banque centrale va
se va être elle-même en tout cas avoir
l' autorité prudentielle unique de la
zone euro et peut-être de l'europe très
près d'elle mais les deux ne se confonde
quand même pas pas plus qu'elle ne se
confonde totalement france comme vous le
savez l'autorité prudentielles et très
proche de la banque centrale ne se
confond pas avec la banque centrale mais
je dirais que la fiscalité est vraiment
du ressort des gouvernements et à ma
connaissance la banque centrale ne s'est
jamais considéré si vous voulez comme
pouvant se saisir d'un dossier de
fiscalité ex ex nihilo
si elle est consultée elle ne manquerait
pas effectivement de donner son
sentiment mais je n'ai pas souvenir si
vous voulez que nous ayons nous-mêmes
travailler sur la fiscalité offre 20 sur
le la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
à ma connaissance des gouvernements le
font ils le font depuis la crise de
manière beaucoup plus acharnés
qu'auparavant et il y a maintenant ce
qui n'était pas le cas auparavant
un large consensus et le concept de
juridictions non coopératives comprend
le gafi la lutte contre le le
le financement du terrorisme
et ceci est très important et nous
sommes impliqués en tant que banque
centrale dans ses opérations de lutte
contre la criminalité et la criminalité
organisée
sur le plan prudentiel concept qui fait
partie du concept du concept de
juridictions non coopératives dans la
mesure où nous avons maintenant des
responsabilités où nous aurons des
responsabilités partout en europe nous
manque centrale bien entendu cela fait
partie de nos responsabilités sur le
plan fiscal comme vous le savez sont les
gouvernements eux mêmes dans le cadre de
l' ocde et du forum mondial qui
organisent leur propre coopération même
si je dirais bien volontiers
qu'effectivement ce concept du joli
surnom coopérative est probable au le
bon concept pour ne pas brouiller le
message et être très clair vis-à-vis des
pays concernés et je ne dirais pas
seulement des places offshore concerner
un des pays concernés monsieur le
gouverneur de la part de nos collègues
de notre rapporterait de moi même jour
merci de la profondeur de la précision
et de la pédagogie de vos propos voilà
pour les travaux de la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur le rôle des
banques dans l'évasion fiscale si vous
souhaitez les revoir ou en savoir plus
sur ce thème notre site internet
publicsenat.fr bonne journée à tous